as many of you know I like Bernie
Sanders a lot I think he has great
policies he's one of the most
progressive candidates running along
with Elizabeth Warren I'd be thrilled
for Bernie Sanders to be the Democratic
nominee and take on Donald Trump but
when people I like do something I
disagree with I say it and Bernie
Sanders has made a major mistake in
naming a woman named Linda Sarsour as a
campaign surrogate now I know I'm going
to get crushed for this by a sliver of
the left people may cancel paid
memberships they'll be angry that I have
the audacity to call out a woman who
happens to be Muslim an identity
politics argument but I am making the
effort not to self-censor and I just see
this as a mistake Linda Sarsour is from
the toxic wing of the American Left she
is someone who has played coy with and
refused to denounce anti Semitic Nation
of Islam leader Louis Farrakhan she is
someone who has participated in
marginalizing Jewish women in her role
as founder of the women's March which
I've previously talked about
I don't believe Bernie Sanders should
have anything to do with Linda Sarsour
this is simply a mistake plain and
simple the Bernie campaign over the
weekend tweeted a video of Linda Sarsour
speaking where she is identified merely
as a civil rights activist and 2020
surrogate of Bernie Sanders but the
truth is that she has a very very ugly
past again Linda Sarsour is a founder of
the women's March he's one of the three
founders I've told you about before
along with Tameka Mallory and Bob bland
who allowed anti-semitism to pervade the
movement who didn't consider Jewish
women important to the movement and
marginalized them who played coy Andrew
cozy with anti-semitic extremist Nation
of Islam leader Louis Farrakhan who I've
widely denounced before and it shouldn't
be difficult anyone who cares about
civil rights and non-discrimination and
inclusion no matter what your political
ideology is you should just denounced
Louis Farrakhan it shouldn't be
difficult and Bernie should have nothing
to do with this and in fact she has
blamed white women for the anti-abortion
heartbeat bill that Georgia tried to
pass she has defended Sharia law
in a series of tweets trying to put a
positive spin on it other left and
Democratic groups have figured this out
for example the DNC ended its support of
the women's March over exactly what I've
described to you before having people
like Linda Sarsour in the picture is
what hurts our own credibility I don't
care about Linda Sarsour personally this
is about what this does to the movement
to have people like this involved even
on the israeli-palestinian conflict it
quite frankly doesn't seem like Linda
Sarsour and Bernie Sanders are on the
same page Bernie has repeated many times
when Israel is attacked by rockets it
has a right to defend itself he makes
clear he's not going to play the
demonization games that lots of people
like Linda Sarsour play we just don't
need them all of the productive views
that Linda Sarsour might hold are held
by plenty of people who aren't toxic and
who aren't associated with people like
Louis Farrakhan she wants Medicare for
all
great so do I she wants two ition free
college and a $15 minimum wage lots of
people on the left do there's no reason
to make her a surrogate for Bernie
Sanders it's not my left I'm actually
surprised this is even something that
Bernie Sanders would entertain given his
track record he may simply have no idea
what's going on with Linda Sarsour but I
would encourage the left not to dabble
with this toxic wing because there is
literally no upside there's no policy
upside there's no ideological upside
there's no public relations upside even
if you don't personally find Linda
Sarsour problematic even though I
believe that you should
there is no strategic argument to be
made for her involvement in Bernie
Sanders campaign period now if you
disagree with me let me know but try to
do it in a way that's respectful right
let's let's see if you can actually do
that because I know exactly what I'm
bracing for by even talking about this
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show while you're there follow me on
instagram at david pakman